vous êtes policière sur la route et vous
avez été percuté par une voiture lors
d'un contrôle qu'est ce qui s'est passé
il s'est passé un beau championnat
comme tous les jours tous les jours une
nation aux anneaux comme vous vous
demandez à des voitures devos m tous les
jours les joueurs refusent de se
soumettre à un contrôle d'identité en
contrôle routier nous agressent sur des
cartes de victimes souvent away vont
contrôler parce que je suis arabe
chinois alors que non je vous contrôler
pour un motif jetant pour moi adrien
nous tarde amalgame
bien sûr il ya des bavures il y en a qui
sont racistes on peut pas dire le
contraire serait bien de mauvaise foi
clairement mais son refus d'obtempérer
l'individu percute cinq voitures qui
percute une dame 1 donc on essaye de
l'arrêter parce que c'est un danger
public
il nous percute notre véhicule à
plusieurs reprises et on en arrive à
l'arrêter à ce moment là on sort tous du
véhicule arnaud pointe est élevé
sauf que j'ai pas eu le temps de prendre
une distance d'une un périmètre pour me
mettre en sécurité - m et il me l'a volé
en avait marre foncé dessus en me
laissant sur la chaussée ça ça c'est
inadmissible de 0,2
on entend la été appréhendés c'est
toujours en cours quoi vous avez réussi
nous apprend il vous a percuté oui il
martin de tomber mais c'est un chu
tomber avec l'adrénaline je réussis à me
relever
j'aimais les séquelles cinq minutes
après quand j'ai réalisé vraiment ce qui
fait passer non mais alors qu'est ce
qu'il en est où cet individu vous a
perdu c'est marrant les demis les flics
ont été en termes éthiques
l'observatoire est face à un individu
c'est difficile encore dan on condamne
les violences qui peut être commises par
certains policiers
et on a raison de le faire il faut le
faire parce que financièrement ça
distingue cette minorité de policiers
qui n'a pas sa place à pression de
l'immense majorité qui fait son job
correctement mais en même temps il ya un
paradoxe quand je vous entends gens vous
êtes en train de nous expliquer et on
peut tous se comprendre et vous parlez
beaucoup de sincérité de vérité qu'on
est dans une société de plus en plus
violentes de refus d'obtempérer tous les
jours de que des agressions verbales
tous les jours des provocations tous les
jours certes il ya une grande paradoxe
que le discours politique qui dit qui
vous soutient mais quand on regarde dans
les dix dernières années treize mille
fonctionnaires de police de moins quant
aux regards dans les dix dernières
années 2000 crs de moins pour faire face
aux manifestations
quand on regarde les dix dernières
années on est passé de 12 ou moins de
formation quand on a la police à 8 ou 6
mois on a supprimé en 2015
l'épreuve gestion du stress c'est pas
rien quand même dans un métier comme
celui là on a dans la police nationale
plus de 25 millions d'heures
supplémentaires impayées on a des gens
qui gagnent des salaires
pitoyable par rapport au job qu'ils font
quand on est gardien de la paix ou
brigadier je pense je parle du bas de
l'échelle et un métier extrêmement
difficile
il faut savoir que sur les
manifestations où on a eu des tirs de l
bd qui ont arraché des mains crever des
yeux les tirs de l bd la plupart qui ont
été portées ne l'ont pas été par les
gendarmes mobiles et par les crs qui
sont des professionnels de l'ordre ce
que je voulais dire qu'à la fin ils ont
été portés par des gens qui ne sont pas
formés à l'ordre public l'économie sur
le terrain le samedi avec elle mais des
100 heures de formation ouais en fait il
faut aussi qu'on parle de ça oui il faut
qu'on condamne les violences qui sont
faits par quelques policiers qui sommes
qui n'ont pas leur place à police il
faut qu'on parle aussi de cette
corporation qui est en souffrance
ces quatre suicides par an sur dans la
police nationale était bonne mais les
chiffres y a pas été donné par grégory
mais grégory bien mais ça va vite il ya
5 % la police reprend 7% des
fonctionnaires en france 56% lundi 17
janvier
tout à l'heure vous avez dit quelque
chose de très important et on verra si
monsieur vous pouvez nous confirmer
vous nous dites que des policiers sur le
terrain par tours de terrain en sachant
qu'ils n'ont pas la capacité d'
interpeller techniquement parce que j'ai
oublié vous avez interpellé donc vous
partez sur le terrain formé au cou je
vais l'attendre à madame donc vous
confirmez monsieur le syndicaliste voran
porno le dire que vous savez que vous
n'avez pas la technique
d'interpellations nécessaire et vous
n'avez pas la capacité d'interpol et
c'est machin avec les d'étranglement
pense que c'est clair les meilleurs avec
rappel n'a pas la technique et voilà on
nous apprend pendant un an sauf que pour
nous perfectionner il nous faudrait des
stages
il faudrait des formations continues
bien sûr mais on n'a pas les moyens
est ce qu'on appelle les moyens nous
aussi on aimerait être filmée avant les
caméras piétons et là les militaires ça
sauf les caméras question faut savoir
que certains en nous mais il ya cinq
minutes de démarrage pour avoir le
l'écran d'accord vous pensez vraiment
que l'on me suis maintenant pensons un
ton déterminé cela il peut s'en passer
le ministre je vous disais fin est liée
au gel damon allen a été clair sur le
sujet il faut vous avez parlé d'un poème
de formation d'après mme d'équipement et
la prison que je montrais clair sur le
sujet et est par ailleurs je rappelle qu
effectivement beaucoup de postes ont été
supprimés mais c'est ce gouvernement qui
a décidé de remettre dix mille alors des
emails recrutement ça se forme pas en
trois jours vous l'avez dit on prend des
gens avec 8 de moyenne et inférieure aux
concours
c'est parce que ces attaques insurgés
dans la police quel est le message
politique parce que chacun dit le sujet
politique le message politique il est
extrêmement clair d'abord la police elle
est le reflet de la société
ça ça nous interroge chacun sait ce que
j'essaie d'exprimer tout à l'heure et
deuxièmement nous ça nous en état doit
tout le monde est soumis au droit est la
police les dirigeants c'est la
démocratie c'est comme ça que ça se
passe
vous entendez et donc toute violence
commise dans est adroit elles sont
toutes les violences illégitimes ont
vocation à être détectés et identifiés
poursuivis et sanctionnés c'est aussi
clair que ça dès lors qu'on établit que
non violence est illégitime et a
fortiori dans la police qui pour le
cours des prérogatives particulières
parce qu'ils ont droit d'user de la
force et c'est vrai qu'on leur demande
peut-être encore plus aux policiers
parce que eux ont un usage légitime de
la force
et quand forcément cette force
cette violence légitime elle est
détournée de son objet ça paraît
effectivement insupportable pour les
citoyens il faut entendre tout ça le
sujet c'est certainement un sujet
d'abord de confiance de toujours essayer
de toujours mieux se comprendre ce sujet
de formation sensu et d'équipements
c'est un sujet transparence et je pense
que de ce point de vue là ton président
de la république et que le musée
l'intérieur ont posé un cas très clair
et ce cadre il a vocation à nous qui
sommes les négociations quand même
malgré tout d'avoir demandé aux
policiers d'avoir géré la contestation
sociale pendant deux ans quand vous
dites qu'il ya eu l'exercice légitime de
la violence tous ses mains arrachées ses
yeux les éborgné ce n'était pas légitime
et pourtant il ya eu aucune sanction par
rapport à ça à aucune des victimes
aujourd'hui deux n'ont pas n'ont pas vu
que les enquête de l'igpn ou d'injustice
notamment on faisait donc en fait vous
avez jeté toute une corporation qui est
là pour défendre le droit qui est là
pour défendre l'état de droit qui qui
qui fait vivre notre droit fondamental à
tous à la sécurité est en fait vous
l'avez envoyé pour faire de la gestion
politique de l'opposition